all right as title 42 is set to expire
at the end of the month president biden
is sending mixed messages when it comes
to his border policy u.s officials tell
the associated press that the president
is quietly sending migrants back over
the border this after striking an
agreement with mexico to take up to 100
cubans and 20 nicaraguans a day the deal
is set to expire may 22nd one day before
title 42 comes to an end
here to discuss is the texas department
of public safety lieutenant christopher
oliveiras
christopher thank you for coming i want
to bring that map up one more time i
want to just note that the president
is talking about we're talking about
areas in san diego el paso and the rio
grande valley so 100 cubans and 20
nicaraguans a day
why do you think the administration
is being so hush-hush about this
well good afternoon nina and thanks for
having me on so i think going back to
what you just said earlier it's mixed
messaging uh well one thing to take into
account this only they're only going to
expel 100 cubans 20 nicaraguans and when
you take that into account of the
thousands that are coming across daily
just last month just by sources that
i've talked to some of our federal
partners there were between 34 35 000
cubans for one single month and you're
only going to deport 100 so and also
keep in mind too that they're doing
these increased rapid expulsions that
are tied to 42
but yet they want to they're not
intended to uh keep title 42 they want
to lift title 40. so it kind of goes it
kind of it's just total hypocrisy right
there what they're trying to do as far
as trying to do this rapid expulsion
they're trying to 42 but yeah they still
want to live title 42 come may 23rd so
again mixed messaging but what it comes
down to anita is the fact that this
should have been taking place from day
one having these conversations with with
mexican officials and one thing that
we've been doing ever since we launched
operation lone star initiative by
governor greg gavin and even to date
what the governor abbott has been able
to do by signing those four historic
agreements with mexico our state
leadership are having consistent
conversations with the mexican
authorities last week alone in an eagle
pass we worked collaboratively together
with the mexican authorities and we're
able to control and contain an area
along the river in eagle pass and even
today in laredo texas we're doing the
exact same thing because we are working
with the mexican authorities to try to
contain and control those areas where we
see increased activity
yeah those numbers are just astonishing
i mean right now
migrant apprehensions are at a historic
high 1 million encounters since january
what happens when title 42 expires the
dhs secretary warns there could be 18
000 migrants crossing per day do you
believe that i mean what are you seeing
there
well that's what i've been hearing too
as well by talking to the the men and
women that are on the front lines our
state partners our federal partners all
the local law enforcement that works in
these smaller border communities that's
what they're anticipating with the
lifting of title 42 18 000 a day which
is not going to be sustainable to these
smaller border committees that already
have a strain on resources because of
what they're seeing right now and that's
why the state of texas we're having to
bear this burden we're having to take on
this responsibility to provide all these
state resources state funding uh to try
to secure the border but again it all
falls back on what the federal
government needs to do as far as
enforcing these policies that were
effective prior to 2021 but again i can
tell you one thing too for a fact too
anita is that in march we saw a historic
number of 221 000 on the southwest
border encounters i can tell you just
from the people that i've been talking
to for the month of april is going to be
historic and if it's confirmed what i'm
hearing we're going to see the highest
number of encounters in u.s history for
the month of april so just supposed to
show you that even though yeah just goes
to show you that even what they're
trying to do it's not it's not making
any type of significant impact along the
border right now
all right a big job on your hands
lieutenant chris oliveiras thank you so
much for your time today sir john hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else